this category of questions are called
solving trigonometric equations right
they're equations it says find solutions
and there's just trig
all the way through it okay so let's
start with this top one
um i haven't i've not pulled any punches
okay these are both hsc
style questions i could have given you
like an easy one to start off with but i
thought nah it's thursday we're gonna
run our time
okay so let's have a look at this guy
find all solutions
and then they throw at you what looks
like a fairly complicated mess okay now
what we're gonna do is
turn this complicatedness into something
much more um
much more tame that we can deal with
okay so does anyone have any suggestions
what might be a first step we could take
to make this better to deal with because
it's like a disaster
right now sorry
okay so i want to get this into a form
that we know that's for sure
what where we're gonna head i will point
out for all of you maybe some of you
already realizing this
it's gonna at least take me three or
four lines to get to that point
okay um do you want to suggest what can
we do practically
okay so you're looking at this um this
constant here
now it is going to sound strange but
even though it might
initially look simpler to add two to
both sides then we just have the trig
stuff on the left hand side
i will suggest that in this case and in
most cases like this
actually that will be counterproductive
it's good to keep everything on the left
hand side okay
what are you thinking john x is to
change that
identity okay fantastic so sorry i think
you were starting to head there right
now for those of you who are like wait
what was he just talking about if you
have it there
go pull open your reference sheet okay
now here's page one it's pretty
simple stuff we don't look at page one
very much to be honest
page two you can see a lot of the trig
stuff comes in
and what john's referring to is this guy
here underneath trigonometric identities
so you can see right down the bottom
uh cos squared plus sine squared x
equals 1
right cos square x plus sine squared x
equals 1. this has a name by the way
does anyone know what it's called
it's not important if you don't know its
name but it's called the pythagorean
identity because if you've got a right
angled triangle its sides can be sine
cosine and one in the unit circle right
so this is literally
pythagoras a squared plus b squared
equals c squared but with trig
okay so how can we use this well if i
note i'm going to say i'm going to
literally write this uh this
first line welcome is probably not
essential but
for the sake of our working so you know
what's going on i'm going to write it
for us
since we have this identity of our slave
cos squared plus sine squared equals 1.
therefore as john suggested that sine
squared x
in the top line i can substitute it if i
just rearrange this line a little bit
right i can say since that is true sine
squared by itself is equal to and john
went straight to this line actually
1 minus cos squared x you okay with that
right now
why is this helpful to us why is that a
good substitution to make into our first
line any takers
shane barbie
fantastic so part of the problem here is
you've got sines and cosines mixed
together
but we're going to make this all in
terms of cosine and then we can work
with it
okay so let's go ahead we'll make the
substitution therefore
2 outside of i'm not going to write sine
squared x
i'm going to write the substitution 1
minus
cos squared x and then i'll write the
rest of the line
okay now this already looks healthier
right um i can start to expand some
stuff something's going to cancel
what happens when i expand what do i get
out the front
2 minus 2 cos
squared x and then everything else right
now
you can see in this case it's just like
super lazy right that two
and that minus two they're just going to
cancel so that's great that's one reason
why you know strange suggested we we add
two to both sides
there was not really much point to doing
that even if they don't cancel though
right suppose you'd have to write this
but suppose it was like a 3
out the front there right even if they
don't cancel you still want everything
on the left hand side because why
why do we want everything on one side
tyler what are you thinking
it's easier to work with i'm going to
factorize eventually you want everything
on one side so you can factorize okay
in this case the factorization is really
quite straightforward you've got -2
cos squared x there plus cos x
um what can i factor out cos x
that leaves me with uh this guy here is
going to turn into 1
and then this guy here is going to turn
into
two cos x so i'm actually going to write
that we usually write things with the
positive first
so one minus two cos x
there we go that's equal to zero okay
now i feel like this is
sort of mission accomplishing that now i
can work with this
there are two parts to it sorry that's
bothering me let me fix that
there are two parts to which we're going
to solve independently
two factors which we will get solutions
from in each case right
so if you've got something times
something and they equal zero
um either of them could be equal to zero
and you get solutions right does that
make sense
so we can do this if that's zero
then the line will be true and then also
if this is zero the equation will be
true
okay now just before i go any further
hands up if you reckon i could take it
from here
i could manage hands up straight okay
can i give you a minute or two
you're going to get a bunch of solutions
out of this but i'm going to pause
because i think we're at a much more
comfortable point
i'll come around have a look and then
i'll show you how we combine everything
together okay
off you go okay now
i was wandering around having a quick
look
so let me bring you back together now
the first thing i'm going to say
is you should find four solutions
if you didn't find four solutions
something has gone wrong that's the
first thing i'm going to say
the second thing is i notice a lot of
you like kind of a worrying number of
you actually
start to solve this problem this one
right here and you started to think
in degrees now i don't that's not a bad
thing objectively to do because we're
more comfortable with degrees
we can come up with those answers
especially for exact values much more
quickly
and reliably that's nice but i'm going
to give you all the warning number one
you would not believe how many students
think in degrees and then they forget to
come back
to radians the domain is in radians we
must supply our answer in radians that's
the first
danger um the second one is you're just
not gonna escape
radiance like you might as well start to
get used to this thing right it's kind
of like
living in a foreign country to begin
with you're like i don't know how to
speak this language
well if you're gonna live there long
term you might as well start learning
the language even as a novice because
it's going to
help you make sense and i know radians
can feel like a
foreign language raise your hand if you
drew a graph
on your page anyone one person
okay hooray someone all right
all right sure all right now you will
see i drew a graph it's not a beautiful
one
but it's gonna be my primary instrument
to know what my solutions are
for um these two parts of the equation
so for starters
cos x equals zero the graph is
immediately the best place to go here
because if you were thinking of
quadrants
or um the triangle all those kinds of
things right
you're kind of already up the creek
without a paddle because
both the quadrants approach and just
using a triangle rely on the fact that
we define
cos as adjacent on hypotenuse right
that's how we start off yeah
well if a json or hypotenuse is zero
what kind of triangle you got you don't
have a triangle there's no adjacent like
it's a side of no length right the
problem that leads to the quadrants
diagram is you know for the quadrants
you've got let's just quickly draw it
right you've got
a s t c um the c for example what does
that mean
it means cos is positive in that
quadrant um the t
means that in this quadrant uh cos would
be negative
right so you know where it's positive
you know where it's negative is cos
positive or negative
and the answer is no it's not positive
it's not negative
the quadrants will not help you because
you're actually on border lines right
which is
kind of tricky the graph eats this for
breakfast right